[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Alexis in Athens Georgia starts this
hour off Hi Alexis how are you
hi Dave I'm good how are y'all better
than we deserve what's up
so I'm 22 years old and I'll be
graduating in May free with a bachelor's
degree in mathematics awesome for the
last four years thank you for the last
four years I've been training to join
the Air Force and I was selected to be a
pilot but last week I was medically
disqualified from the Air Force and now
I don't know what to do with my life
what happened can you share I don't want
you to be too of course forthcoming but
what's what's going on with this
preclude you from flying any plane or
just the Air Force
now more details as though we go on
since it quite literally was a week ago
but basically some medical records from
2012 relating to Mental Health
have disqualified me okay
well first thing I want to say is I'm
sorry because I we can hear when you
were 11 years old
yes sir when I was 11.
wow yeah are you okay now from a
practical standpoint
yes sir I am
um it's been rough but
I kind of looking at this is almost like
a second chance since I pretty much
signed up I'm sorry I mean have you
recovered from what happened when you
were 11. oh
officer actually
it was a false diagnosis
oh my goodness
okay so here's the deal Dave that that
it's frustrating and maddening and
disappointing but the good news is is
you can still fly the friendly Skies it
may not be for our military because of
who knows what government regulations
and are involved here but you are not
disqualified from flying planes true or
false
I don't know honestly well if it was a
false diagnosis well I guess my point on
an 11 year old child
yeah you're not I'll just tell you yeah
you can get a pilot's license okay I
don't know I mean and number one we need
to go you need to go back and work clean
up your medical records and uh put some
notations in there and so forth so that
if somebody else sees this they
understand the absurdity of it it sounds
like right
yes sir okay but yeah I don't I don't
think I think you can be a pilot I think
Ken's right it's just a matter of now
the path is a little more uh strenuous
because now you're paying for flying
lessons right
I'm actually not sure if I I don't think
I want to be a pilot
okay so now I'm confused yeah I am too
so
my main
goal with the Air Force was I wanted to
be an Air Force the job wasn't
necessarily
the driving force factor it was being in
the Air Force and now that I've had time
to
think about
like basically that dream has been
destroyed and kind of think about my
life I don't think that flying is the
end-all be-all and
what did you want to do in the Air Force
let's just pull the Air Force aside what
did you want to do let's assume that
this didn't happen you get in you fly
and then you start to make your way up
I'm assuming you had a ladder in mind
what would you be doing in the Air Force
ideally yes so some of the Milestones
that I wanted to hit along the way was I
wanted to be a instructor at the Air
Force Academy and I wanted to teach
mathematics one other goal that I had
was to become an astronaut
and okay so overall just
so let's just focus on what we can do
can't be an astronaut because of the Air
Force unless you somehow can appeal this
and get this cleaned up if I were me I
would look at all avenues to try to get
this false diagnosis cleaned up and I
would try to appeal that would be me I
would fight until I cannot fight any
longer however unless you've just
decided you no longer really want to be
in it yeah if the Air Force was the goal
to instruct in the Air Force I'd fight
but if you just want to instruct
mathematics you've got all kinds of
opportunity to do that and you can teach
at a very high level you were not
limited in your desire to teach to
instruct mathematics and maybe be
involved in aeroscience but you know in
the private sector if that was the path
that I would be going as close to that
as possible if I can't be an astronaut
how could I support space and
exploration in the science there I think
you have a bright path and I don't think
you're in any way limited to do that I
think the Air Force is obviously a place
you had in your mind is a great
destination but you shouldn't be stopped
at all I understand why you're
discouraged but let's get refocused if
you want to fight on the Air Force great
if you don't let's move forward you've
got the degree you're debt free you're
ready to go
yeah there's nothing holding you back
here it's just it's a it's just a
radical change of Direction which is
emotional as it can be
and so yeah uh uh but I I think Ken's
right I know I would go get the medical
records disputed cleaned up whatever
whatever the process is there
um because that that may frustrate
something else in the future who knows
um but the uh and then just decide okay
what is it I want to do what parts of
what I was going to do in the Air Force
are still appealing and how can I do
those in the marketplace
um I mean SpaceX we've got commercial
applications of space exploration out
there now that are open to mathematics
Majors I'm sure and so I'm not sure
you'd be an astronaut on that kind of
thing but I mean you could work in the
field for sure if that's what you want
to be around and utilize your
mathematics degree so you got a lot of
options I'm sorry you uh you know you
got you got sucker punched I mean you
got you just kind of cruising along and
boom you know and so now you just got to
reset rethink and it's a normal human
thing for that to take a minute but it
doesn't it doesn't take a year no it
takes a week that's right and just re-re
okay I'm not going that way am I going
that's right what's next what's next
what's next and you know this is your uh
first opportunity to get back up after a
after a fall after a rejection and the
way we get back up is by refocusing on
that end result our good friend hearing
Cloud calls it a desired future and for
you remember it was I want to instruct
in math
and then I want to be involved in the
space program so I've had some things
dictated to me but I can still do all of
those things nothing is limiting you and
so begin to focus on the change you
always wanted to make
in that initial narrative and so now the
story is still whole it's still the
exact same goal it's just different way
different place different path and I
think that will really snap you back and
and and uh you'll find that you'll be
more resilient as a result of this
disappointment that's what I want people
to hear that have been burned lately and
disappointed you're going to be more
resilient you're going to be tougher
you're gonna be okay you still have a
lot to give
absolutely hey Hang on we're going to
sign you up for uh Ken's assessment his
career assessment and you can go through
that it'll give you some insights too in
um the get clear assessment uh it'll
help you get clear and on some of those
New Direction change so a lot of
opportunities for you you're gonna do
great you're amazing this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money John is
with us in Salt Lake City hey John
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how y'all doing things taking my
call sure what's up
um so I'm just trying to to figure out
uh when it makes sense to leave my six
figure uh salary position to jump full
time into my side Hustle
what's the side Hustle
um I I started a company and we sell
mobility vans to disabled people and
companies oh wow how long you been doing
that and how much income is it
generating
um so we've been this is our fourth year
um it's grown by 30 every single year
last year generated uh 375 000 in net
income and three million in sales nice
what's your projection for this year
uh 475 and about 4 million nice so if
you have a net income of 475 000 why do
you need to keep a six-figure job why do
you even need to ask the question
you know what I I that's probably what
I'm questioning myself there's a lot of
safety blinking things here good health
insurance good retirement security for
my family you know I I have 475 000 will
buy all of that
no I I don't disagree I I feel also I
think I feel a sense of loyalty to this
organization to try to help where I can
but I I find myself very distracted
right now yeah you think
how many employees do you have besides
yourself
it's just me it's just you and what do
you make in the full-time job working
for somebody else
uh 114 000. okay so the the Dave's right
but the simple let's just play this out
practically
can you pay yourself a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars out of this 475
based on all the other expenses
and from your side hustle without a
doubt yeah so it's a no-brainer I I just
you know there's there's a false
narrative here that you have more
security working for someone else than
you do for yourself that's a false
narrative
unless there's some facts I think that
you can come up with
no I think early in our marriage you
know finances were hard we struggled it
was paycheck to paychecks so for us to
stop we've started other businesses that
have failed and this one just really
exploded so I think I have some
hesitation because of the fear of what I
experienced in the past
um I I've run 48 months of financials
you know the average income is 28 000 a
month over 48 months it's a good data
set so I think it's just a there must be
a personal battle I'm dealing with
listen you're absolutely terrified
because of your past and I love the
courage to say that but that's what's
going on but you've got analysis
paralysis here and and you're you're
busy you're holding down two jobs and
you're crushing it my friend how much
more I think the question you got to
focus on is how much more could you grow
this company if you were full-time
working for you all right let's stop a
second just pretend that you made 475 in
the coming 12 months for starting from
the day okay
that's four years
of income at the other place
yeah so even if you blow it up at the
end of the year
you got three years to figure out what
you want to do
yeah not a really good point and that's
that's only dedicating about 10 hours a
week to the business yeah okay you know
what you need to do yeah you need to
quit the other job
um I mean give them reasonable notice
but you need to tell them today yeah
you're you're used to you overstayed
you're welcome you shouldn't be there
you shouldn't be there Lara Lara is in
Boston hey Laura welcome to the Ramsay
show
how can we help
I have a question regarding
um my parents estate and me and my
siblings inheritance my parents have
asked me and my sibling if we wanted to
inherit the house that we grew up in In
This Moment In Time my sibling doesn't
necessarily want to take full ownership
when you know when that day comes
um in this moment right now I would love
to
um but so you know knowing that that's a
potential that you know could change my
parents could sell it if you know later
on in their life
that's what they choose to do they have
obviously they should do what's best for
them but in the meantime knowing that
you know if that is an option someday I
would like to have that be you know my
home and keep that in the family how
should I go about managing my money with
that in mind should I pretend like it's
not gonna happen
what was that I said pretend like it's
not going to happen go live your life
and then and then if you get the house
then figure it out then
okay because how old are your parents
um my oldest parent is 70 Tia okay are
they ill
um one of them is is
they're in okay Health okay have they
got 20 years though they probably do
possibly 15 or 20. and you don't put
your life on hold for a house you might
or might not get 20 years from now no
rock on kiddo just rock on and if you
get the house later if at that moment in
time this still looks like it's
something that's appealing fine if not
just sell it turn into money
got it okay and then if I I currently
have a mortgage that's my only debt and
pay it off if
um if but if I get to that point and I
still have a mortgage I would recommend
15 years from that
all right you need to get rid of the
mortgage quit letting this potential
thing that happens way out there in the
future dictate a change in good common
sense and planning
okay yeah you should you should just say
that's out there it might might or might
not happen it might or might not change
some things and if it does it's just
extra it's just gravy on the biscuit it
is not the biscuit you take control of
the controllables run your life and then
then when this happens or doesn't happen
it doesn't throw you all a skew because
you haven't counted on the wrong thing
so yeah it's perfect on that that's what
I would do yeah focusing on the now and
how I win now and not worrying about all
these things that could happen in the
next is the right strategy because now
I'm I'm trying to win now as best as
possible Wellness something that's out
of your control and if it is affecting
the next five years negatively because
you might get this 15 years from now
that's really done that's right you
start waiting on it and then you wait to
do anything else yeah that's that you
know it's like I yeah absolutely don't
do that no go go be somebody go be great
make things happen be awesome get the
house paid off have you a big old pile
of wealth and then if this comes along
well look at it then and we'll decide it
may become less and less interesting the
more and more successful you become
that's a very good point yeah so all of
a sudden yeah you know it's just a it's
just a house it has wonderful memories
and I hope and nuances and things
because it was your your
you know your childhood home as you said
and so that's kind of cool but I
honestly um I and I feel nostalgic about
my childhood homes different ones we
lived in but I wouldn't care to own a
single one of them yeah just not worth
it yeah no no not not in my world today
and it's not it's not because I'm a snot
it's just they they don't fit in my
world the way my world is now but I'm
old so there you go
seasoned seasoned experienced there it
is that's it yeah lots of experience
well financial literacy month here of
the month of April and this from Forbes
high school should high schools teach
financial literacy more states are in
more States and more states are seeing
yes and of course we think that's a
great idea at Ramsey because we have a
high school curriculum called
foundations and personal finance that's
taught in about 48 percent of the high
schools in America about six million
students have been through it and uh we
think that if you're gonna out there and
walk around as an adult you ought to
know how to do it this article says in
April Georgia enacted a law requiring
high school students to take a half
credit of financial literacy as a high
school graduation requirement Florida
Michigan Nebraska Ohio Rhode Island all
the past laws recently too Texas has a
law I'm throwing that in other states
including South Carolina Minnesota and
New Hampshire have similar legislation
making its way through the legislatures
over all 12 states require or soon will
require a stand-alone financial literacy
course as a prerequisite to graduation
uh well I mean
you're going to use that more than the
Pythagorean theorem that's correct
so hello I mean if and moms and dads you
ought to be all for this it keeps them
from wanting to live in your basement
later
because they know how to handle their
own money and they're not freaking out
we picked up an article a while ago this
kid bought Crocs instead of paying his
bills what during the pandemic 20
something year old Crocs
for God's sakes yeah you need a
financial literacy class for sure for
sure Croc
not to do that that's true I know
they're back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
tomorrow
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well we just finished up an incredible
smart conference last weekend in
Nashville our new Ramsey Event Center
full of people it was rocking a Friday
Saturday night or Friday all day
Saturday incredible incredible
incredible and so this week we're
announcing the fall smart conference
will be in Chicago
September 15 and 16 with all the Ramsay
personalities me Rachel Cruz Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman George Campbell and
uh the greatest hits the greatest new
hit we've got Jade warshaw she'll be
we'll all be on stage for this two-day
event and get you motivated and fired up
to keep attacking your goals you're
going to leave with a plan to improve
every area of your life your money
mental health relationships career hey
it's all there listening to the radio
show is one thing but being live with
thousands of other people that share
your enthusiasm for a quality life oh
it's a pretty cool thing to do and uh
part of it is you're going to get the to
be there for a live recording of smart
money Happy Hour podcast with Rachel and
George and the fun doesn't stop there we
got surprises all day long it's a packed
out thing tickets start at just 79 the
VIP and platinum type tickets go really
really fast so you better get on these
really quick
we've got a ticket that actually
includes dinner with me and the other
Ramsay personalities after the event
there's only 60 of those I guess super
Platinum tickets or whatever they're
called so uh they're going to go really
fast but they're not 79 I promise so
not even close so anyway check it out
smart conference September 15 and 16 in
Chicago and go to ramseysolutions.com
events and get signed up as fast as you
can we're gonna really really looking
forward that's gonna be a great event
this last weekend was a lot of fun
incredible energy the crowd was
absolutely on fire and obviously really
fun to have everybody on our campus a
lot of fun yeah it really was it was
packed out and
and I mean there was no drop off it Just
Energy upon energy upon energy it was a
that the crowd had to leave exhausted I
know we did but uh I mean they were
because there's just so much there I
mean your segment with the uh the whole
thing was so emotional I mean it was
just man I was back there crying and I
knew what you were going to do yeah you
didn't sneak up on me so I mean it still
got me it was just really really good so
check it out folks don't miss this
George is going to be in Los Angeles hi
George how are you
better than I deserve what's up
got a quick question I guess it could be
a little bit more complex but basically
uh I have a dilemma about splitting uh
property taxes or how to go about uh
giving up the money on our tax return
from property taxes in a shared
household
a shared household
yeah so my I my wife and I we live in
the same household as her parents we
have our own side of the house but the
property is one property who owns who
owns the house
uh my wife and her parents own it three
ways
three ways
yeah so they they purchased the home
before we got married and then I came
into the home and my wife and I we have
our side of the home
okay so they the the mom and dad owned
two-thirds your wife owns one-third
yeah that's correct why would you not
split it that way
uh because with the basically when we
looked to our tax consultant they told
us that the best strategy for us would
be to claim the house because the
difference in our taxes for us cleaning
the house my wife and I would be a total
of fifteen hundred dollars for my
in-laws it was a 400 difference
if they claim the house with the maximum
benefit and if we split the uh there's
nothing how you don't claim a house you
mean if you take all of the property
taxes
yes you're going to pay all the property
to lower your tax bill
yes that's dumber than a rock
okay your tax consultant needs to be
fired or an idiot
because here's what's happening you're
paying out ten dollars on taxes to say
15 or 20 are paying out property taxes
of ten dollars to save a dollar and a
half
to two dollars on taxes that's dumb I
think it was that it might be the
interest I'm not I'm not a tax doesn't
matter interesting doesn't matter okay
if you're actually having to pay the
entire tax bill property tax bill or
interest bill in order to get the tax
write-off
then you're putting out a ten dollars
every 10 hundred dollars in order to
save fifteen dollars
you don't you don't save a hundred cents
on the Dollar on a tax deduction man
yeah it lowers your income
that is taxable yeah but and at your tax
rate is the only actual savings so yeah
I bet it does save you but it also
increases the uh the out-of-pocket
expenses by 10 15x in order to save you
fifteen hundred dollars no thank you
okay you can't claim the interest if you
didn't actually pay it
no we yeah we we paid the interest and I
guess because my wife is owner in the
hall we can either claim a percentage or
the whole interest on the uh on our tax
return did you pay all of the interest
why did all of the interest was paid why
I thought she's only one third owner
well between her and her parents it was
paid
okay dude you no caring or they would
have foreclosed
obviously somebody paid it but my point
is did your parent did her parents pay
two-thirds of the interest and you all
pay one third of the interest yes or no
uh yes okay then you can't claim the
part that they paid you didn't pay it
even if you wanted to you can't
the only way you can pay it is for the
claimant is for you to pay it because
you get audited you have to prove you
paid it
again your tax consultant is apparently
a so yeah you really need to move
on number one you can't a tax consultant
tells you to claim something you didn't
actually pay you're going to get
hammered by because you lied in an audit
number two if you did actually pay the
whole thing in order to get the tax
break that's trading a dollar for a
quarter you never trade dollars for
quarters and people that's what tax
write-offs are you trading always when
you increase your expenses
artificially just to have a tax savings
it it cuts it only saves your quarter on
a dollar so you don't do that so no no
no no no fire your fire your consultant
yeah I mean you know Dave you were
pretty clear on that one I don't think I
can add any to that that was pretty good
okay so let's go back because people do
this crap all the time particularly
small business people out there you're
the worst and I love you but man you
just kill me so you're cause you're
stupid CPA will say something like his
tax consultant or whatever it is will
say you need to increase your expenses
so you have some write-offs
well that's dumb right okay you don't
increase your expenses
you know okay so I'm gonna go spend ten
thousand dollars that I don't need to
spend
that ends up saving Me 2 500 on taxes
yeah
that's just dumb yeah
I mean how do you how do you get a CPA
if you're that bad at math how do you
actually pass the test it's very
interesting Beyond me you never increase
actual cash expenditures
that on things you don't need now if you
need them for your business anyway or if
you're paying the interest anyway then
for God's sakes take the right off but
you're probably you know George you're
probably not taking the right off anyway
because we've got such high standard
deductions now that most people take the
standard deduction they don't do
itemized and if you don't do itemized
you're not writing off your property
taxes and you're not writing off any
interest
so only uh 12 of Americans 88 percent
took the center deduction only 12
percent last year actually itemized so
you're probably not even itemizing or
shouldn't be
but not mathematically again because the
deduction your standard deduction is
probably much larger than these other
write-offs that we're talking about so
it makes more sense to take a standard
deduction married filing jointly
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys we know a whole bunch of you
knew were out there if you want to know
more about where you are how to move
forward on the stuff we talk about here
all the time
check out the get started button at
ramsesolutions.com go to
ramsaysolutions.com click get started
it's completely free we'll walk you
through exactly where you are and then
what your next steps are and you'll
begin to learn the lingo around here and
of course if you're enjoying this show
please follow And subscribe and share
the show tell people about it send a
link or click the share button or
whatever however it is you're doing this
or if you're listening on talk radio
just share the fact that you're doing
that hey I'm listening these Ramsay guys
over there man and and they're on such
and such a channel tell them where we
are you watch it on TBN tell us tell
them where we are whatever it is
wherever you are share tell people we're
here and uh that helps us guys leave a
five star review that helps us uh one
star is not necessary mama said if you
had anything nice to say don't say
anything at all Joe is with us Joe is in
Akron Ohio hi Joe how are you
good how are you doing Dave better than
I deserve what's up
hi so uh
uh question
to go and
it's kind of been on my mind so
um
my company that I work with has a stock
option so they I have a stock allowance
that I get and I when I started at my
job back in May last year
um I had like a big lump sum of like
130k that'll invest over the next four
years in the stock of this company that
I worked for and
I I don't know what to do with this so I
we've kind of me and my wife we after we
started listening to you we we just paid
off all of our debts so we're completely
debt free except for our house last year
way to go and
um we
really are just thinking like we want to
get this house paid off like we we just
bought the house last September but we
we see this money sitting here and I
don't really like it being an all-in-one
stock and I don't know whether we should
put it in mutual funds or whether we
should just as soon as if that's it so
it's gonna invest every quarter for the
next four years I'd cash it and put it
on the house cash that out and put it
right towards the house yes yes it's
exactly what I would do and here's how I
know I would do that reverse engineer it
and that's called a sunk cost analysis
that'll help you okay reverse engineer
it so if if your house uh let's just
pretend the stock is you know you're
able to vest and pull out twenty five
thousand dollars of it okay and there's
an example okay and you you were to
throw that at the house and reduce your
mortgage from what is your current
mortgage
uh we
okay so let's call it thirty thousand
dollars you cashed out and you drop your
mortgage from 480 down to 450. okay
now reverse engineer that if I owed 450
on my house would I go borrow 30 000
more
to buy stock in this company
no
no okay and so by reverse engineering it
the answer becomes very clear what you
would do
and nor would you go borrow 30 000 to
put it in mutual funds
so you know right so I'm putting it on
the house I'm getting this house paid
off as fast as I can congratulations on
a great benefit big stock options like
that when you get signed up is good yeah
absolutely and then to be able to put it
on the house and that creates a ton of
momentum what does that do for someone
when in one Fell Swoop you knock that
much off your mortgage payment there's
130 Grand over the next year or a year
and a half or three years I think yeah
for it to vest out but yeah yeah so it
is about 30 40 000 a year they're coming
out that's pretty cool yeah and maybe
it's going to continue maybe he'll get
some more I mean that's great hopefully
so it's just it's just found money yeah
and we're just good all found money
you're on baby step six goes at the
house goes at the house goes at the
house that is the right way to go Ken
how much of that kind of thing uh stock
options are you seeing in the hiring
world uh certainly in public companies
if you're on an executive level Junior
executive level and even sometimes on
the very large because it increased in
the last there's not 4 30 seconds I
don't see anything with the weirdness in
the labor market I don't see any data
that says it's increased I think it's
probably pretty much standard price
practice you might see what you might
see is is it a slight decrease when
you've got major public companies that
are laying people off which is very
interesting Dave because we've seen a
lot of news in a lot of news about
layoffs but they're largely tech
companies Salesforce meta which is the
Facebook parent company Google and they
just over hired and so we're still
seeing that people that are getting laid
off are getting replaced on average
they're replacing their job within a
month so we still have a very low
unemployment rate March job numbers just
came out we're at 3.5 percent
unemployment so we don't even have that
no because we actually have way more
jobs available than we do by the
millions so it's a negative it really is
technically if the unemployment rate was
properly calculated that's correct it's
an Arcane archaic process that sucks
yeah yeah we have about one and a half
jobs available for every person who is
filed for unemployment to your point the
number there exactly so yeah there's
plenty plenty of work just there's a
shortage of Labor America labor crisis
an event you and I are doing with Mike
Rowe and uh with a few other thought
leaders John deloney Michael Easter that
in the comfort Crisis book we're doing
that on May the 4th uh you guys need to
sign up for that uh is there a free live
stream on that and you can get tickets
if you want to come sit in the
auditorium Mike's coming in from LA with
me the day before
um and picking him up while I'm out
there and where he's going to come in
and she'll be on the Ramsey Event Center
Stage and um and you know then we're
gonna get the rest of these guys to join
us and talk through this America's labor
crisis because hiring for small
businesses right now is at a crisis
Point that's right so that's a way to do
that for sure Adam is in Charleston
South Carolina hi Adam welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks sir thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so my wife and I are babysat
millionaires good and
yeah we have so we have a million
dollars
um but we're renting right now
and we're trying to decide where to buy
and how much house to buy we recently
moved to the Charleston area in the high
rent district we never thought we'd buy
a half million dollar house in our life
but now we're contemplating that
so wanted your advice on you know if I
sell some of the Investments we have
I'll probably have to pay the capital
gains tax on it
what do you think about
um what you know what kind of how to
finance a house purchase
uh for someone in our situation
how old are you
37. cool what's your household income
two hundred thousand wow and how much of
the million dollars is one million
dollars exactly and how much of it is a
non-retirement
about half of it is in
um 401ks and you know stuff that I'd
have to pay a penalty to get it out yeah
we're not touching that
yeah I'd cash out the rest of it though
pay cash for this house
even though I'd have to pay I think I'd
have to say 15 right yeah
yeah well that's not on half a million
dollars it's just on the game
sure yeah so if you had a hundred
thousand dollar gain it's 15 grand
if you've got 400 bases in the 500 000
worth of Investments you got 100 Grand
gain you got fifteen thousand bucks so
what what do you do if you pay cash for
your house dude
yeah
yeah you know what it's weird when
people say capital gains like you and I
are having this discussion my buddies do
this too I catch them all the time that
there's a drama there's capital gains
you know inside your head I say it does
that to me when I say I got capital
gains yeah like it like like acid just
got thrown in the thing because it's
Un-American that's how it feels it's
just it's just wrong but yeah but the uh
uh but I mean
but then when I do the math it's like
it's 15 grand man I mean shut up just
buy your buyer to have a half a million
dollar in your hand yeah and if you're
sitting there with a half million dollar
paid for a house and a half million
dollars in your 401ks and you make 200k
and you're 37. you understand that it's
67 your net Worth's probably going to be
between 15 and 20 million
yeah yeah because you got Pure cash flow
when you don't have a stupid house
payment and a half million dollar house
in Charleston South Carolina is going to
go up no question oh my gosh what a
wonderful Market
yeah you feel like uh there's still room
for
the market to go up here dude you're
asking a 62 year old guy that used to
see houses sell for twelve thousand
dollars that question
that's so true that's beautiful
yeah absolutely I buy real estate every
day man I love real estate I just love
it and certainly your personal residence
yeah yeah Charleston is so wheat grave
Market I'm being there in a heartbeat
hey man thanks for calling in you're a
good guy you got your act together way
to go proud of you this
is the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Ken Coleman Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Ken Coleman show
talking about work and careers as my
co-host today
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
Allison is with us in Seattle hi Alison
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it sure what's up
um I just have a question for you
um a long time I'm a long time listener
we've listened for about 10 years
and I just am curious about your own
personal story when you went through
bankruptcy
it seems like if I understand correctly
you became a millionaire pretty quickly
after that or if I'm incorrect maybe I'm
incorrect on that but I just am
wondering how how did you do that it
just it seems so slow to pay off our
mortgage and so I'm a little bit
discouraged like I see all these young
kids on YouTube you know doing all of
these I don't know investment type
things where they're built like buying
duplexes living in half of it you know I
forget what that's called but I'm just
curious it just seems so slow
uh no it was about 10 years
for us 10 years um
uh we filed bankruptcy in 1988 and it
was probably about 98 or even the year
2000 somewhere in there before we hit a
million dollar net worth I guess I've
never gone back and looked at it but
it's somewhere like that it was not it
wasn't that fast uh what do you make
what's your household income
about 105 000. okay and uh how has that
increased over the last 10 years
quite a quite a bit I mean my husband I
think he started around
65 maybe yeah okay
um and so you you have just your home
left to pay off
yeah it's it's probably worth market
value right around 700 and we owe about
99 on it okay
but we don't have any in
into yeah I didn't want you to sell it I
just was asking what was going on okay
so you got a you got a 700 000
uh you know piece of net worth there and
you've also got surely you've been
saving for uh retirement through that
time right
yeah we we do the 15 in the 401K and
Roth IRAs yeah and how much is in there
I don't know I haven't checked that for
a while oh roughly
uh
Maybe
so maybe you're a millionaire and you
just made 100 Grand Max
that's pretty good
well I don't know about I don't know
well I mean if you're if you did if you
have 250 000 in your 401ks and you have
a 750 000 equity in your house that's a
million dollars
yeah
yeah I guess maybe yeah let's assume
that you have a fast forward button
because I'm hearing some angst here I'm
just curious if you fast forward I think
you've been watching crap get rich quick
stuff on the internet and you thought
there was an easier way to do it than
you've been doing it with the income
you've had you've done an amazing job
what do you want on the other side of
this what's on the other side of paying
the house off let's assume you've done
that what do you want
you know I really don't know I've kind
of asked myself that question as well I
just I think I think I come from a long
line of on both sides of my family
elderly grandparents and
great-grandparents dying without with
nothing
and I just I'd like to have a better
quality of life when I'm older I guess
you're already on your way in a
spectacular fashion you're not dying
with nothing
yeah
how old are you and your husband
I'm 44. he's 46. yeah what does he do
for a living
he's an electrician
yeah he's already increased his income
does he worked for himself now
no no he works for a utility
yeah but he's still a young man and you
know a natural progression for him to be
to start his own company and become a
millionaire just in that business alone
plus what Dave's already laid out for
you guys I just think this is so
fear-based that you haven't been able to
look at your own life and your own
reality and see how good you're doing
yeah one third of the people that we've
studied that became millionaires did so
on six-figure income or less
and that's you wow that's you wow okay
so far I mean you just now got over a
hundred right
right just just in the last year yeah
yeah and so you did everything to this
point that you've done on less than a
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
told me the house is worth what
right right around 700. okay and you owe
100 so that's a 600 000 Equity I said
700 I was wrong okay she was 600 000
equity and if you've got 200 250 000 in
your 401ks and Roth IRAs which you need
to go look up tonight you all need to
sit down and talk about this
because you're you're stewing about this
and don't even know the numbers
yeah that that because sometimes just
knowing the numbers will relax you
so here's the thing let's pretend that
you got
um
uh 300 000 in there that's nine hundred
thousand dollars
okay very close to a million you follow
me 600 on the house plus three in the
other very close to a millionaire 44
years old that's a long way from dying
old and broke
yeah
and so yeah John deloney talks about
when you're running into these emotional
things and you're you're running the uh
the catastrophes over and over in your
head that facts are your friends they'll
gr they'll kick the drama queen out of
your brain
facts okay facts will do that so sit
down look at the facts because here's a
fact okay let's say that uh your net
worth grows at an average of 10 a year
because you're invested in good mutual
funds and real estate does well in the
Seattle Market which it traditionally
has done for the last 30 years okay now
Seattle could screw it up and you know
cause it to fall in on itself like some
of these other cities have done but
let's just assume that Seattle continues
to be a Boom Town okay
and so if that happens your million
dollars is going to double every seven
years
so you're 44 at 51 is going to be 2
million at um
at 58
it's going to be 4 million
at 65 it's going to be 8 million and
that's if you add nothing to it
see what I mean by Factory State numbers
yeah facts are your friends
that's if things go up 10 a year if you
got your mutual funds and your and your
real estate goes up 10 a year now it may
or may not go up that much it may be a
little bit less but I'm not that far off
my point is not is that you know it's
going to double it if it doesn't double
every seven years it's going to double
every eight years you know whatever it
is it's still going to be pretty close
and that's without adding anything to it
and you're going to continue to add to
it so you're you know
you your chances of becoming your
relative that died broke is close to
zero I mean you're doing so good way to
Go Allison go get you a mirror and pat
yourself on the back
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back they're one
their wash and guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
well this is the day that those of us
that pay taxes are the most pissed off
tax day America
some people don't pay taxes so they're
not real worried about it but I do and I
don't like it
they should have election day tomorrow I
think it might change the way people uh
think about how they vote if they had
the sting of taxes in their mind
yeah yeah uh if you put off filing your
taxes because the process feels tedious
or confusing we understand but if you
owe Uncle Sammy wants his money and if
you don't file today you can get hit
with extra penalties and interest on top
of what you owe failure to file is a
problem don't do this get filing so it's
time to find your tax software get this
behind you file in a tax extension
otherwise but you really ought to just
get your filing done most of you it's
just like a term paper you've been
putting it off and kicking the can down
the road if you want to do it the quick
easy way you got an easy uh return it's
not super complicated just use Ramsay
smart tax it's inexpensive it's quick
and that'd be our professional
recommendation and it's not just because
it's got a name on it it makes the
process really really simple you'll save
up to 70 percent on that when you switch
from other tax software and we won't try
to sell you credit cards and other
things like TurboTax will
and uh also if you want a tax
professional uh we've got the endorsed
local providers if you've got a
complicated return click on ELP for
taxes we'll help you just go to
ramseysolutions.com smart tax today is
the day oh my gosh all right sway Is
With Us in Kansas City hi sway how are
you
hey Dave how you doing today thank you
for taking my call sure what's up
so I'm currently in baby step number two
I have roughly 66 500 uh dollars in debt
um 21 000 of that is a
is a vehicle
I make about 40 000.
um what do you do for a living
I drive a dumpster truck I do long waist
men uh
um I pick up lawn waste okay like leaves
and grass clippings
okay what's your question
um
currently with the way it's set up it'll
take me
about five years to
to get out of this hole you got twenty
one thousand dollar car what's the rest
of your debt
36 000 was because I decided to do an
I.T technical program here in in Kansas
City
um to try and
um essentially supplement the income
that I lost after my divorce
and um I just I really
um messed up that opportunity at the
time and since I started listening to
your show I actually
took some accountability and some
responsibility for the mistakes I made
and I asked him if I could reset the
coursework and I'm on a wait list
because that was kind of the only thing
I could think of on how I could really
make more money
so quick quick quick follow-up question
we'll get to the money stuff you s you
signed up paid a lot of money for this
IT Tech course you didn't finish is that
what I'm understanding
correct so you don't have the
certification that you were paying for
but you've paid in full
correct okay but they're gonna let you
go back through we hope yes we hope yeah
cool and you're what are you studying in
Tech what are you what are you doing
can you repeat that sir what what are
you studying at the technical school I.T
security awesome well there's gonna be
that's gonna increase your income my
friend which will help us get out of
debt really fast if you apply yourself
it's kind of the goal and I I was
considering going here uh your show in
Kansas City this week because I'm not
really passionate though about it Tech
but I've listened enough shows to where
this could kind of be my like short term
it could be short term yeah well we'll
take care of you probably gonna beat
dumpster truck yeah yeah when we're done
I'll give you two tickets to my event
Thursday night to break through event in
Kansas City at Union Station we'll help
you with that but let's let's tackle the
rest of this money stuff and I'm hoping
they'll give you the credit or allow you
to take that course my friend I'd fight
hard for that
thank you I'm really hoping I'm hoping
to know by Friday if I make the wait
list or not otherwise uh my mom says you
know all things happen you know in God's
time and so do you have family you got
small kids a wife or anything
you got a divorce I'm divorced too I
know kids I have a nine-year-old who
will turn 10 on the 24th and I have a
four-year-old daughter here's why I ask
whatever time that you have when you
don't have parental rights or whatever
you've got to be working more than just
this truck right now while we're waiting
on this technical thing to fix up we've
got side work side economy is blowing up
right now where you can go and make an
additional uh big chunk of change every
month and get some momentum my friend to
work the baby steps you ought to be
working like crazy when you're not with
those kids
and and honestly I am
um I was doing and that's kind of one of
the things because my car's not fuel
efficient
I was doing ubereats and doordash both
of them and I was only making maybe 100.
so let's not do that let's go work in a
warehouse let's go do late night grocery
I mean my friend the the yeah anyway you
have any technical skills at all as far
as the tech part goes
no I didn't I really I just I jumped
into it because of great marketing I
could have a new career in four months I
have
um I just really it's just a high school
education and so I was stuck at like the
labor at lately uh like yeah Uber each
is not the only thing you can do as an
extra side hustle I was hoping you had
some tech skills you could start writing
some code while you're doing this stuff
but that's okay the ubereats is not the
only thing driving is not the only thing
and oh by the way you maybe sell the car
because it's 21 freaking thousand
dollars and you only make forty
and so that's kind of where I was um
I do have a beater and so the reason
I'm in this situation with their vehicle
and live scale they kind of wanted your
guidance was my mom essentially took it
out in her name because I had totaled my
truck but with my total truck money went
after my divorce I bought a a 2001 Honda
Civic beater uh
three months into his engine blew up put
a new engine in it like it's my point A
to point B car
and I ended up with this Explorer
because she wanted me to continue my
side hustle at the time I had a lawn and
a tree and Lawn Company
last season
I had to put over I I was in the red I
kept getting damage to my my zero turn
mower and it was costing me more money
to hold the business than have it
and so I got oh
vehicle absolutely whoa whoa okay that's
absolute bull people make money in lawn
care every day with zero turn mowers
that turn tear up
you absolutely you weren't mowing enough
was the problem
you need to mow more
man I'm that that's absolute crap the
Zero Turn Mower put me into the red said
no one who runs Lawn Care
ever
we mow more and we make more money than
the mower teardown you break mowers as
part of the business but you make more
than that so dude what happened is you
got the snot knocked out of you in this
divorce and every time everything we're
talking about it's got this this uh wet
blanket on it everything we're talking
about oh this is bad and this is bad and
this is bad and this is bad so right now
today is your day's way to change the
way you need to lift your chin up start
looking forward I know you've got a
bunch of pain in the past but you need
to start happening to some things with
some zest some enthusiasm some energy
and a smile so get in there and happen
to this dadgum I.T thing get this done
get this stupid car sold or get back in
the lawn business man you can make so
stinking much money with in a lawn
business that
went in the red because your Zero Turn
Mower broke oh give me a break
dude really while Dave was talking I
pulled up a warehouse associate job no
degree required no previous experience
23 dollars an hour is the first thing I
pulled up the opportunities are there go
work and start getting some wins but
hang on the line I want you to come be
my guest uh Thursday night Union Station
the Breakthrough event hang on the line
we'll get you two tickets bring somebody
else that'll fire you up let's go let's
go let's go let's go it's time man it's
your time it's your time right now go
get it this there's the Ramsey Show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Mary is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Mary welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so um my husband ever mentioned to me
that he had a second 401k account from
his previous employers and I came across
all this while we were doing the
budgeting
um and mind you we've been doing
budgeting for like a very long time the
question came about because we have a
sixty thousand dollar credit card debt
and my question was well can we pay some
of it from the 401K and I think that no
you're totally against that right yes I
am but the bummer is that he never did
tell me he had another second 401k
which amounts to almost 250 000 dollars
so he's still putting you know money
towards that 401k plus the current
employers 401K no he's not
you can't add to a 401k at a company you
no longer work for
you can only add to account 401K in a
company you actually still are employed
by
okay 15 okay yeah you're putting 15 of
your income towards retirement right now
yes that's what he's putting in
in the current employer
in the current employer he's not willing
to take the money out because he says
it's not feasible
feasible no I wouldn't take it take it
out of the 401K or you mean he's not
willing to stop adding to it
correct he's now willing to stop adding
to the 401K well it's not feasible is
the fact you people still have 65 000 in
credit card debt that's straight up
stupid
right I agree with you 100 well so his
statement his statement is asinine
I'm gonna keep putting money in this
while we overspend over here and never
reduce our credit card debt that's dumb
so we were making the we were making the
account and trying to figure out how
much how how much more you're going to
be losing so he's putting in
and his company matches you guys are not
you guys are not in agreement on what
your goals are
okay you need to sit down and decide
what we're going to do with our money
and if you're going to follow the Ramsay
plan of getting out of debt so that you
can become wealthy faster
then you would stop your 401k
contributions temporarily while you
attack this but y'all have been playing
footsie with this he sort of kind of
goes over here to the side does whatever
the flip he wants to do you go over here
and try to clean up his mess on the
other side
y'all aren't working together
you're working against each other
you're not going to get this money stuff
straightened out as long as you do that
it's yeah I I sit down and I tell him
look this is what's going on no that's
not how it works you don't get to tell
him anything we have to decide together
that we want to follow a path to become
wealthy
and he's not even listening no matter
what you tell him you're just sound like
Charlie Brown's teacher in the
background wait wait wait wait
that's what it sounds like to him
because he's not even on board he's just
tolerating this thing that you're doing
so the two of you need to sit down and
say together what are we what are we
going to do honey I need your help with
this I need you to come alongside me so
that we can get out of debt so we can
become very wealthy because what we've
been doing for the past several years
has gotten us to where we are and where
we are sucks and I'm kind of tired of
this sucking stuff and I wish you would
get tired of it too and we could work
together on this
but right now you feel like you're
trying to drag him and you're getting
increasingly disgusted with him and he
probably tired of hearing you nag yeah
yeah am I missing something
no sir yeah so I think this is a
marriage communication thing the Bible
says where there is no vision the people
perish you all don't have a vision for
where you want to go together
like if Sharon and I decide we're going
to go on a trip and I don't know make up
a we're going to go to Florida okay then
we decide together that we're going to
Florida otherwise I gotta duct tape her
and throw her in the back seat and take
her to Florida and that's that's a
problem it's problematic it's called
kidnapping so you know it just doesn't
work so we have to go we have to talk
about do we both want to go to Florida
yeah then we can talk about what's the
fastest way to get to Florida are we
going to buy airline tickets are we
going to get our little butt in the car
and drive down there you know you can
get all kinds of methodologies once you
both agree on the goal together but if
if I want to go to Florida she don't
want to go to Florida I end up in
Florida by myself yeah and Mary I would
just mention this credit card debt I
would mention what it feels like as Dave
touched on but I would I would introduce
some numbers to the conversation this is
what we're paying every month in credit
card debt and this is the interest
they're charging us and and appeal to
his sense of money you're scared share
I'm scared this is not working and when
I get scared I get mad and then I start
nagging you and I'm tired of being a nag
I don't want to do this and I'm tired of
you not listening to me too you know we
got to get on the same stinking page
here man this matters yeah and then you
all decide together what you're going to
do and that way you're not pulling in
different directions and set a vision
for where you want to go that that
that's what's missing here
um
is you're trying to do
all these Ramsey tactical things that we
teach and both of you are not doing it
yeah I was going to ask you is we listen
to this story
he's looking at it we we presume he's
going well I don't want to give up that
retirement money to try to pay off debt
and I think it needs to be a complete
switch of it's not just about them my
friend it's about what happens if you
pay off that debt you get on the other
side of that and all those credit card
payments now turn into the baby step
plan it's like he's so focused on
stopping he doesn't want to stop
investing in his 401k that he's missing
everything else well I mean it feels
like you're saying with credit card debt
making you know paying 18 on it
you can't think that's a good 20-year
plan exactly no one logically can go oh
that's a wonderful plan let's just keep
doing it it's more like I hate that that
it's over there but I just don't hate it
enough to do anything about it yet right
right you know you got to hate it you
got to get sick and tired of being sick
and tired and busted in the mouth and
that's when you yeah that's when things
start moving man nothing moves unless
it's shoved and so you get sick and
tired of being used to have that I've
had it moment and then you're willing to
do whatever it takes to get there that's
when you start moving stuff around in
your life particularly money stuff it's
exactly how it works Mickey is with us
in Jacksonville Florida hi Mickey
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Ken thanks for taking my
phone call I appreciate it sure
um I just have a quick question so um
for the last five years my husband is
kind of been feeling a call to pastoral
Ministry and
um we were just so we're in baby step
two currently or I'm sorry we're leaving
baby step two and we were trying to
figure out if there was a way for both
of us to go back to school debt free
um I don't know what your thoughts are
on that he was he's currently an
aircraft mechanic and
um he's thinking about making that you
know just following the path he feels
like God God has on his life
and um I don't know what your thoughts
are what's your path because you said
both of us yeah so I'm a stay-at-home
mom primarily but I do work part-time
um for about 10 to 20 hours a week just
depending on the week yeah but why do
you think you need to go back to school
or why do you want to go
fishing counseling to help support his
ministry um and then he would go back to
school for pastoral Ministry but then it
would also you know allow some room for
income in the case that he does decide
that he needs to stop being an aircraft
mechanic altogether if that makes sense
he can't decide that because y'all don't
have any food if he does
you have to have food yeah
so pastoral Ministry is going to be a
part-time gig and you can guess what you
can start at a church tomorrow you don't
have to have a pastor's a seminary
degree to do that yeah right some
denominations require that but most
don't so you can start and you can start
volunteering at your local church now I
suspect you both already are aren't you
we are good good so let's find a way of
a path into pastoral Ministry that does
not involve 250 000 worth of Seminary
degree when you're an aircraft mechanic
trying to feed two kids that's right and
besides grants and scholarships you're
going to have to save which means be
patient you both may not be able to go
to college in the same season you're not
you ain't money it's not happening
you're broken in debt so you're gonna
have to lay out a game plan that gets
you there gradually and incrementally
and it may be that he becomes a pastor
without a seminary degree that's not
that unusual
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
contacted us a couple weeks ago and said
there's a article in the hill
showing that uh up to 50 percent of
American families are paying their adult
children's bills
to a tune of an average of fourteen
hundred and eighty two dollars a month
wow
and
um
the
and the vast majority I forget what the
number was no it's up to 25 percent of
Millennials their parents are paying
their housing meaning they're paying
their house payment their rent or
they're living in their basement I don't
know which
um this is um
I've never seen it like this
the the and and it's and so I did an
op-ed that's on the on the front page of
the Fox Web right now in Fox Business
web uh on this subject and it blew up
the op-ed blew up
um just like this I mean I had a thing
on social media last week that got 32
million views it blew my mind it blew up
just and it was a clip from a couple of
years ago of me taking a call from uh
these people that were almost a million
dollars in debt and only 200 000 of it
was their mortgage I mean they were just
it was amazing and I was I don't know
why the thing blew up it's calls we take
here all the time I really couldn't to
see anything different but something was
special on Tick Tock and it just went
nuts so I guess that Tick Tock
generation just had never seen they've
not seen that I've seen someone actually
and know the answer to the question and
care deeply about the people on the
other side care enough to tell them the
truth yeah and we tell them the truth
tell you the truth here sometimes you
don't like it but we always tell you the
truth but this this thing of parents you
and I have been talking about this a lot
in America right now with a labor crisis
we're going to talk about it more on May
the 4th with this thing with Mike Rowe
that we're doing uh and you guys ought
to sign up and watch that uh live stream
that we're doing because this labor
crisis is tied into this loss Mike Row a
dirty jobs and I were talking this loss
of work ethic
we've forgotten how to do hard things
that's right yeah there's two houses or
a thing of the past yeah yeah there's
two things that I think parents have
eliminated over the last few decades
hard things and scary things hard things
where it's not scary it's just really
really hard I'll give you an example my
father first job I got I was 14. he went
and got the job he knew I needed to work
and he made a couple connections but he
specifically chose a job that he told me
years later he goes I wanted you to
taste really brutally hard work and I
had to go up on a ladder day for a local
painter that he knew and I had to scrape
paint off the side of a house with a
propane tank in one hand and a scraper
in the other and you know I'm 14 my arms
were as big a round of strings and
you're just it's painful it was
exhausting work and he told me I wanted
you to taste hard work so number one you
could do it number two that you would
set your sights on something higher
that's a hard thing and scary things are
allowing kids to fail to try an
instrument Dave to to to to maybe try a
small business to try a sport to do so
they actually keep score yes and you
don't get a trophy unless you win yeah
well that's a whole nother issue it's
part it's part of the problem yes part
of the problem oh yeah it's it's a big
issue a psychologists call when you pay
your kids bills psychologists call that
enabling yeah okay yeah and the rest of
us call it stupid
and you're not helping you're not
helping no because the the Little Eagles
are not gonna soar unless you kick their
butt out of the nest
then you no eagle ever flew with the
nest attached that's right never
happened so the helicopter parenting oh
the participation trophies I don't want
my child to ever hear or see or
experience anything negative it's not
good for you no we've got we've stunted
good for you need to experience uh
winning yep and you winning is not as
fun unless you have also failed yeah
well you don't appreciate winning until
you've lost the sting of loss is what
drives Champions and and you're right
Dave this participation stuff we we've
laughed about it for decades and now
it's playing out in the workplace here's
how it's it's unrealistic and unmet
expectations this is what it looks like
in the workforce right now and it is
these kids have gotten trophies and
parties just for showing up you know
what's weird is that it's not all of
them not all so they get thrown under
the bus like gen Z and Millennials get
thrown under the buses all be in this
and they're not because I got 400 of
them working in the building here the
traditional they're hard working they
care deeply they're passionate they'll
charge the gates of hell with a water
pistol man but then you know they got
their friend over here who's mommy's
helicopter and the irony of irony you
know your 28 year old son lives in your
basement and in an act of sheer irony
spends his day playing Call of Duty yeah
that's something irony of that yes he
doesn't even understand you know what
duty is and he's never answered a call
yeah oh my God and this is what plays
into this Dave is that now parents feel
bad because their kids are not
struggling and so now they pay their
bills for them industry of work Michael
Easter talks about this in the comfort
crisis we have worked very very hard
to because to be comfortable oh yeah and
then we've worked even harder to make
sure our kids don't experience any pain
and it turns out now the data is in
that's a mistake yeah
allow your kids encourage your kids
force your kids to do hard things and
scary things that's right it is so you
get you know stand on your own two feet
there is so much dignity in that
when you have to buy your own bread and
pay your own light bill
because Mommy isn't going to do it you
have become a man my son
oh my gosh and then we wonder why
there's a manhood crisis yeah you know
we wonder why there's a stunted growth
out there and you know it's society's
fault you know I'm triggered
kiss my butt you're triggered get off
your tail and go do something it's
triggered yeah give me a break see
that's that's the problem we create
terms like that to describe real
emotions that everybody's a safe space
yeah ain't no you don't ain't one Heaven
that's it right that's a safe space
until you get there yeah not going to be
safe but isn't that the truth accept it
and get on with it yeah you know I can't
have a car that doesn't have 73 airbags
I mean you're telling this to a
generation you used to sleep in the back
window while they were driving down the
road we didn't have bike helmets or
elbow pads you know what it made us
better bike riders because if you
wrecked you stuck to the sheets for six
nights those are consequences well it's
gross Dave but it hurts try pulling the
sheet off of your leg Yeah I know
this is very exciting folks it's a rare
moment in the show hey I went farther
than Dave but you know the point is is
that we here's what happened it's a
marketing message that scared everybody
marketing started figuring out that if I
scare parents they'll buy more stuff and
then it took hold we've got the most
scared Society come this whole thing it
comes
from I want good things for my kids and
enablers are always the nicest people
right they don't want their kids to hurt
they don't want anyone whoever it is
they're enabling they don't want them to
feel any pain and the sad thing is what
we're discovering now is is that I
controlled reasonable level of pain in
order to create growth is the right way
muscle is not built unless you get sore
how do you get sore that's called pain
working out you you lift a weight and
your muscle gets sore lactic acid kicks
in but no muscle is built sitting it's
true it doesn't it never has happened
and the muscles of our brains the
calluses on our brains come from
enduring persevering through hard things
that's right stressful things and coming
out the other side and no one's saying
oh here's a safe space I'm sorry you're
triggered that's exactly right now what
you are is you're prepared you're
prepared for whatever life there's a
toughening because you've come through
challenges before you've done hard
things you've overcome scary things and
now you go okay I can take the next hard
thing on I can take the next scary isn't
it interesting that throughout history
that to go from adolescence to adulthood
with every culture but ours there has
been some kind of ritualistic rite of
passage that involves something hard
it's a very good point yes absolutely if
you look at I'm not saying your kid
needs to be put out there in a life or
death situation in order to be okay I'm
just saying maybe they should sweat once
at least at least think there's a bear
that's going to get them at least you
should
at least you should have a callus from
having persevered through a loss and
turned it into a win yeah and and moms
and dads in America doing this for
people you love is an act of love it's
not a big old meaning as a matter of
fact enabling is quite the opposite of
loving
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality host of the
Ken Coleman show and number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Naomi is in
Oklahoma City hi Naomi welcome to the
Ramsay show
good to have you how can we help
so
a company
and she's growing his company's growing
just opened at the Third location and
I have the opportunity to
really be able to choose what I want to
do within the company and I just need
help making that decision on what what
direction to go what kind of business
it's an outdoor power equipment company
okay have you done any work for the
company in the past
yes I've been employed with them for
three years and I work I currently work
part-time because I have two toddlers
yeah what are you doing for your dad's
company currently
payroll
give
me I do event coordinating
and I also manage our software server
phone
computer problems yeah so you know the
company pretty well what's the most
interesting part of the company just the
the interesting areas
um well opening up the Third location is
going to be a big project and so
obviously it excites me for what's in
the future and what the future holds
um and the growth aspect of the company
is really interesting
um and I understand that but what I what
I would normally teach and what I teach
people is is you're looking for
something this is your dad's this is
your dad's company so let's look at it
as a bus and we want to find the right
seat on that bus and that's defined by
I'm doing something I'm good at we talk
about proficiency that's talent first of
all then something I enjoy
like I actually enjoy the work so you
mentioned event planning let's use this
as an example I don't know that you
enjoyed it but just very quickly for you
to see if you enjoyed the event planning
side of things now we've got ourselves a
pretty obvious potential task or
grouping of tasks the organizing the uh
communicating whatever's involved in the
logistics plus the execution okay that's
an example so if you enjoy that work
that's that's a clue okay so then the
last piece that I teach folks is what
are the results of your work that you
get excited about so that's just a quick
run through so of the positions the
seats on the bus right now
what seems to be the best fit you're
good at it or you could certainly get a
little bit of training and experience
you've already got the Raw Talent so you
could pick it up quickly and you really
enjoy it and you care about those
results what's available what's out
there what could you create what comes
to mind
okay uh I mean with the event coordinate
I like a little bit of everything I do
except for the I.T stuff like I know I I
want nothing to do with printers right
so we cross that off the list right so
you're not going to be in I.T we like
event coordinating what else
um and I like the aspect of working with
people and providing them with benefits
and
um interacting with our employees yeah
well listen if I was your dad in this
situation and you were my daughter and
we were talking through this I would let
you test out a few roles that's what I
would do I don't think you have to pick
it right now I think you go okay I do
enjoy the event planning but in this
type of company you're not doing that
all day every day am I correct
as it would be a full-time job probably
a year to two years from now for sure
great so let's try and test out some
other things within the company knowing
you like the event planning part and
once the event planning part in a year
or two becomes a full-time gig you've
experienced enough within the company
you've tried enough things even if you
don't do the job you're talking to
people who perform those roles this is
just simple basic research level like
you would do a book report in high
school or college you see it you ask
questions you dive in and try it and
then you pick and you may end up
creating your own position but I think
that's what you do don't overthink it
just test some things out and talk it
through Naomi there's a difference
between
this company's growing or opening a new
location
that's just describing the bus
what you're looking for is to start
describing a seat on the bus
is the bus a nice bus yes would you like
to be on it yes now you've got to find a
seat and so it's not it's no longer
about oh they're growing they're opening
another location that's that's just
describing the bus you need to find a
seat
on the bus and that that's what you are
going to be doing that adds value
to the organization that it rate it
helps the organization in some way
greater than it costs the organization
because if a if a
company does not make more on employees
than they cost you go broke
and so you have you know and that
includes the owner being an employee you
know and so your dad just can't give you
a position just because it's fun it's
got to add more value to the
organization than you cost
and uh so Ken's right some some trial
runs that some of these seats would be a
really good plan really good plan hey um
Hang on we're going to send you the get
clear assessment that Ken and our team
here built on helping you figure out
what it is you love doing because you're
still kind of right now you've been a
jack of all trades a master of none you
kind of were a catch-all position and
that does give you good visibility into
these other positions but you really
need to hone in on you not on what the
company needs what is it you love what
is it's going to ring your Bell and get
you going and so just hang on and also
pick up and we'll get you that get clear
assessment and by the way folks you can
get that assessment at the Ramsey
solutions.com store uh it only takes how
long to take it takes about 15 to 18
minutes and 30 bucks or something oh
it's 30 bucks and it reveals those three
things what I'm good at what I enjoy and
what results motivate me that becomes
the awareness to be able to identify a
seat once you have the awareness what
happens is you go oh I see it I didn't
see it before it's like the financial
clear path in the baby steps people go I
know there's got to be a way but once we
describe the baby steps you begin to see
there's a clear path oh wait a second I
can do it and that's what this
assessment does it allows you to get a
self-awareness test and go oh I'm good
at this I enjoy this type of work and
these results of work motivate me and
that's the it's it's really a simple but
profound awareness test and that's what
she has to figure out because now she's
looking for that seat absolutely vital
in family business to not take a
position boy that's true just because
family wants you to be working there
you've got to be doing something that
lights your fire and that they get a
return on investment on and so because
otherwise it's going to be a Str you're
going to be a strain
organizationally inside the place and
what does that do to the family because
of demoralizes the team because it's
nepotism and it and it puts a strain on
Thanksgiving dinner
because Dad feels like he's just
carrying you you know you're getting
paid more than you're worth yeah more
than you're adding value because you're
not in the right seat so it's absolutely
vital you find something you love you're
good at and you can carry the water this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you've been in the market for a new
home for a while last year's interest
rate hikes might have put the brakes on
your plans this year rates have bounced
around some they're still higher than
they've been in a long time it's really
frustrating but here's the deal if
you're financially ready to buy higher
interest rates don't have to keep you
from buying the home
not when you work with a good real
estate agent you can trust and gives you
advice based on your local market your
financial situation if rates come down
you can always refinance
so you're not stuck in it uh higher
interest rates means higher mortgage
payments no kidding so you need to make
a bigger down payment and maybe even go
to a less expensive house make it all
work out for now
so if you're ready to buy don't let
interest rates hold you back it's the
best time to buy right now because
there's uh you know it's not going to
get better housing prices are going to
continue to go up and we can't promise
that interest rates are going to come
down even if they do you could refinance
so if you need an agent in your corner a
high octane high protein real estate
agent that knows their stuff
go to ramseysolutions.com
slash agent you'll find the Ramsay
trusted people there
ramseysolutions.com
agent our question of the day comes from
neighborly the Ramsey Show question of
the day is always sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
take your home's efficiency and style to
the next level with convenient solutions
from shelf Genie window Genie and
Glassdoor visit neighborly.com and
schedule home professionals near you
today's question comes from Robert in
Nebraska what's the purpose of a
15-minute interview any tips to prepare
for it I have an amazing opportunity for
a dream job and the first step is a
15-minute phone interview well
traditionally these initial 15-minute
interviews are screeners they're very
General Robert in nature and they're
trying to just weed out crazy to be
completely honest they want to see if
you've got some just basic courtesy uh
and some basic uh communication
competencies what they're traditionally
looking for when I've worked with
companies that are trying to come up
with their interview process so that
that's the purpose of that but the
preparation piece I would prepare as
though it were a 55-minute interview and
what I mean by that is I think there's
three areas that anytime you're you're
doing a job interview you've got to be
able to effectively communicate number
one why you're interested in the job and
there's three ways to describe it the
company express some enthusiasm and some
admiration for the company assuming that
this is true that you actually aren't
just looking for a job that you want to
be here for instance Ramsey Solutions if
you want to be here and I'm interviewing
you and and I don't do much of that but
but I would want to know why are you
interested in working for Ramsey
Solutions the second thing is
it described a personal connection and
again enthusiasm for the product or the
service that you would be engaging with
and then third the actual job
description
tie in some enthusiasm about why you are
interested in doing that work that's
going to get you through the 15-minute
screener and from there you're in a
traditional process but usually that
15-minute interview is limited it's
quick
they want to know if you're worth taking
to the next level our initial interviews
are 30 minute yeah and we call it a
cultural interview internally that's
what it's nicknamed and it is to
um to find out uh is this are you
looking for a job or are you wanting to
join a crusade right because if you're
looking for a job you're out we don't
need people just collecting a check they
end up quiet quitting they got mediocre
Mondays right you know they're just do
as little as they can do to get as much
as they can get we don't need them on
the team thank you very much we know how
you add value right so that that's the
the basic thing I'm looking for uh when
we are looking for crazy she and but
we're also looking in our case and
really other companies are whether they
say it this way or not or whether they
even realize it they're looking for
values alignment
okay some companies the value is you
work all the time 80 hours a week
because uh you're a programmer and
that's what programmers do and we need
you to work all the time
that's the value they have and they're
looking to see if you're willing to do
that in the case of Ramsey we don't work
that way as a you know we got lots of
programmers lots of uh high-end platform
and Technology folks uh some of the top
coders out there on our team making
serious bank and they go home at 4 35
every day we don't we don't work 80
hours a week here
um and so we're the quite the opposite
but we do have values so like you know
we'll ask the question like our CEO
closes the show saying uh you know
ultimately no way to Financial Peace
except to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus how do you feel about
that that's one of our values that's who
I am that's who you're going to be
working for and so do you really want to
work for that person no I think those
Christian people are crazy okay then
probably not aligned on values that's
good glad we figured that out in the
first 30 minutes and sometimes that
happens people just hang up and we'll do
a little Zoom interview and they'll just
hang up in the middle of it they don't
even say it's we've got some really
humorous video it's crazy how people
will ghost you to yourself instead of
just instead of just going you know what
thank you I don't think we're interested
this doesn't look like it's lining up
and you know have a good day they just
reach over and turn the thing off wow
it's like hilarious this is so funny but
that saves a lot of time for everybody
because that person obviously would not
have fit in they would not have been a
good team member and so it you know it
saves a whole lot of time so that's what
we're looking for with the first 30
minutes is are we spent are we spending
our next few interview hours on a
something that has a good probability of
outcome yeah and uh so we're trying to
clear the deck on the ones that don't
and that's probably all they're doing
well you think it's exactly what it is
it's that quick screener to go all right
we're ready to go to the next level of
conversation they're looking for the red
flags and so that's why I flipped that
in that advice to say prepare as though
that's the full interview and share that
enthusiasm for the organization the
actual product or service and then the
actual job description how you think
you're a good fit for that so instead of
showing them potential red flags you're
showing them green flags and that's how
you win that initial screener yeah and
you know they want to you know stuff
like you want to work from home yeah and
uh you want to know stuff like that if
you want to work from home and they
don't you wouldn't want to know that
they would want to know that on the
front exactly right um you know or
flexibility what is it you're looking
for you know in in those types of things
what kind of a culture uh because we're
more of an old school culture around
here we just like come to work in the
building five days a week too we're
we're a work from the office
organization we work at the office and
so all of us yeah and we're all here
every day five days a week is what we do
and so it's just that I know that's just
Antiquated but you know I don't give a
crap it works so you know because people
being around people as productivity and
creativity we've had a lot of companies
discovering that the hard way so that's
what's going on there and uh by the way
those of you that are small business
people out there that are listening
entire leadership podcast or you're in
onto our leadership Elite you're going
to hear me say in coaching you on how to
do interviews to if you have not doing
one of these short interviews up front
you need to do a 15 or 30 up front you
should you'll save yourself a lot of
time yeah you don't look at the Manpower
if someone comes in and you you give
them an hour just an hour you have
wasted so much time by not just because
you often know in five minutes oh yeah
if you're asking the right questions we
teach this you know I mean they walk in
you just go no oh you know oh yeah
that's exactly right so do it on my
phone do it over something that's not
gonna work yeah no yeah you're you're
judging yeah people are judging every
day baby that's what they do yes that's
how life works you know that phrase you
don't judge a book by its cover every
time I hear that I go uh I do literally
I judge a book if I'm looking at a book
in Barnes Noble I still like to go to to
bookstores old school bookstores I look
at the cover and I'm looking at that the
title The subtitle everything we put a
tremendous amount of research into that
so you know stop saying that because we
do judge a book by its cover it's called
a first impression yeah what are we
doing dress like you're going to a job
interview bathe yeah right it's just
amazing I mean just freaking amazing oh
man we were talking earlier Dave about
uh parents your op-eds exploding on Fox
News you want to go check it out parents
should not be paying their adults kids
bills and Dave just slays it it's
unbelief we gotta check it out but we
were talking about that earlier and and
it's gotten so bad that now Dave I hear
stories though I'm here they're showing
up for job interviews show up with them
but we've had them call and try to get
them the job and we're like yes
wait a minute what we don't want your we
don't want your kid
we don't want your kid why because
you're their mother yeah but
but today there are parents who will
show up to the job because their
mother's crazy I don't want them working
here because their mother's crazy that's
a fact she's gonna be a problem I can
just tell you right now oh my God yeah
it's real it's very real this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today uh
one of our favorite things to do in the
whole world is a debt free Scream the
only thing better is a debt free scream
on the debt-free stage in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions and the only thing
better than that's when it's one of our
own team members so absolutely Taylor
and Melanie McMurray are out here hey
guys how are you hey we're great how are
you congratulations thank you so much
well done now Taylor how long have you
been here uh just shy of two years about
a year and a half all right and you're
on the smart dollar team yes sir what do
you do on the smart dollar team so I'm
an account executive on the smart dollar
team essentially smart dollar is a
benefit that employers can purchase for
their employees to help them do what we
did which is you know get on a budget
pay off debt and ultimately build wealth
so I'm sure you could tell the company
that's considering this for their HR
that you did it yeah there you go hello
there's that yeah yeah how much debt did
you guys pay off we paid off 132 850 way
to go and how long did this take 25
months okay and I won't ask your income
because all your teammates are standing
around it's fair and uh that would be a
little bit awkward and unfair but yeah
way to go what kind of debt was 133 so
122 of it was student loans and then
just shy of 11 000 was a vehicle loan
okay all right very cool and you started
this
about a year before you came on here
then yes sir okay cool how long you all
been married uh we got married September
of last year so
yeah oh just recently oh yeah yeah okay
so you started this before you guys got
buried then yes okay all right cool so
Melanie you come into the marriage with
no debt correct yep she's smart yeah
yeah yeah well you're smart you you
marry her that's exactly right she does
have poor judgment
but we'll let her we'll let her pass
yeah yeah my wife does too so it does so
does Sharon while we're at it hey hey
that's a shine when you when you make
that deal right you close the deal
definitely I'll shop my coverage yeah
yeah there it is yeah so what is it like
you marry this guy and he's got debt you
don't have debt and he's got a plan yeah
and when did the conversation happen
I mean this goes back about seven years
ago when we first started dating uh he
wasn't
you know closed off to telling me about
his debt and so once that was revealed I
was finishing up college and I graduated
debt free which I didn't really
understand the weight of that and how
big of a blessing that was until I met
Taylor and I could see the stress he was
under and so I knew about Dave just from
growing up in church but I had never
like taken a class so I asked for FPU
for Christmas and took him with me and
I'll let him tell you a little bit about
that experience that itself was
interesting because one I had no idea
who you were
um and two I did not want any help in
figuring out how to pay off the debt I
was weirdly comfortable being super
anxious and kind of depressed around my
finances because it just became normal
right yeah and uh so the the caveat to
that as well is actually selling whole
life insurance also as soon as I'm going
through FPU and you're talking through
the whole life section I'm like like
I'm not gonna listen to this guy like
are you kidding me
um so like your name became a curse word
to me essentially for about four years
and the kicker of the whole thing was uh
I paid off about 11 000 worth of student
loan debt after taking Financial Peace
and uh I made a dumb mistake and bought
an 11 000 vehicle right before covet hit
and so that was kind of the wake up
moment of I have no job to really go
sell anymore to be able to pay off this
debt and I literally put myself right
back in the same position I might as
well listen to this guy that's held 25
million people pay off debt and put down
my pride and so that's kind of where the
the whole entire plan started
yeah living in California at the time uh
covet completely shut everything down so
in 2020 I didn't really make any money
to actually start this program and so
once 21 came around
um I just decided like I'm I'm gonna go
out and do this thing I'd actually
watched the uh the reset the financial
reset that we had live in 21 and that
was kind of the wake up moment of like I
really need to do this thing and I
really want to marry this girl and it's
not going to happen in California
um if I'm not going out and paying off
this debt and uh anyways the path led me
here I didn't stay in California and I'm
super super grateful for it so very cool
very cool well congratulations man thank
you so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is now that you
did it because really you've been game
on here for just on just a short period
of time yeah yep I mean definitely the
budget like most people say but I would
say even
for us the paycheck planner part of
every dollar is really helpful because
you know you you put a number somewhere
but then you see how it's sectioned out
throughout the month month and that
really helps you
um to stay on point and then having
obviously a community around you I
listened to the show every day for years
on end just to feel like I had a hug you
know and support around me each day yeah
absolutely I mean and to add that as
well
just having someone in your corner
someone like Melanie for me was huge um
she never really gave up on me even when
I wasn't bought into this platform and
so when I finally did get on board and
she was that extra motivation that I
needed each day when this thing got hard
because I mean it's difficult it sucks
paying off debt is not fun and uh having
her in my side having really good
friends and then obviously like she
mentioned sticking to the budget and
listening into the show is super key
yeah you're not only bought into the
plan you came to work here oh my gosh I
mean yeah that's like over the top you
went like 180 degrees from Whole Life
yeah yeah you know he's like I like that
Kool-Aid now I'm gonna sell the cooler
yeah that's exactly what happened I mean
I was I was selling whole life I was
pretty good at it but once I again I
bought in I was driving around all day
long and I didn't have anything to do
other listening to the podcast and I
actually listened to you both
um and Ken you were a huge help for me
in finding where my actual passion and
talent lies I realized that I'm I'm
pretty good at sales I like it yeah um
it's fun but I want to be able to help
people and I could see that the product
I was selling wasn't helping so by the
way that makes a difference when you're
selling something you really believe in
oh totally it's a game changer I wanna
you just said something I want the
audience to hear you said paying off
debt is not fun it's hard yeah what did
you guys do this is this is a this is
getting after it 132k and 25 give me
give me something hard something extreme
what you guys do to get some momentum or
maybe get over a hump yeah
um well on on top of everything that I
did I picked up a side hustle I was
selling solar on the side out in
California and when I wasn't selling
solar I was driving for doordash and
when I wasn't driving for doordash
um I was just literally trying to to
purchase the cheapest amount of
groceries I could buy literally like
rice and beans without like killing
myself so it was truly all in you're
working hard and cutting cut and cutting
yeah exactly yeah rice and beans without
the beans
oh my gosh why to call you guys get out
of you thank you so much I love you your
team's proud of you so how hard is it to
uh be working on a get out of debt plan
while you're selling smart dollar and
you've got all these people around you
uh
I mean that's either got to be
unbelievably supportive or unbelievably
shaming yeah you know thankfully the
shaming was very little
so the the support though uh has been
insane I mean having the amount of
people that I had in my corner coming to
work here
um I realized that when I applied but I
didn't actually know how much support we
were gonna get and how like deep these
friendships were going to be coming how
big of cheerleaders they would be yeah
and I'm super grateful for everybody
that's here watching right now yeah
there's 100 of them gathered around here
they need to get back to work but yeah
it was good yeah
it's wonderful
way to go very very proud of you sharp
couple I'm honored you're on the team
and thank you honored you're doing what
you're doing with smart dollar it's good
good work you're doing so very proud of
you all right Taylor and Melanie from
right here in Franklin on the Ramsey
team 133
000 paid off in 25 months of student
loans in car come down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
very cool
very cool that's fun yeah really fun we
do have a bunch of former whole life
agents here there's a whole bunch of
them well it it kind of makes sense when
they figure out that it's not a good
thing and then they come to work doing a
good thing that's exactly right here you
take the young that's how it works
sharp people man awesome telling you I
got a building full of these Millennials
and gen Z's and they're amazing they're
wonderful he's a crusader that's what
we're talking about that's exactly what
I'm talking about right there this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER of the day Proverbs 11 25 a generous
person will prosper whoever refreshes
others will be refreshed
Henry Ford said a business absolutely
devoted to service will will have only
one worry about prophets they will be
embarrassingly large
it's a great statement I've never heard
that from him I have it either that is
so good it feels like something you
would say I love it yeah that's good I
wish I had am I am I is in Philadelphia
hi Emma welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
good thanks for taking my call sure um
my my question pertains to my husband
and I feeling overwhelmed by our
mortgage payment and just wanting your
advice on the best path forward
okay how much is your mortgage payment
context we purchased
up conveniently the week after we closed
and was unemployed for eight months
thereafter
um he recently did find a new job but
now makes a bit less than what he was
making when we were going through the
house hunting process
um so we are just kind of feeling that
that payment a little bit more than we'd
like to right now our mortgage
represents what did he used to make at
the old job
roughly 150. what does he make now
we're up about 90. why such a pay cut
um it was just a really challenging to
find you know a new
EST time around
so that's weird because there's a
shortage of Labor what's he do
it's just um
you know
taking a more conservative approach to
it 90 is the only kind of guaranteed
income
so is it a base or is it okay so the
base is 90. correct how long and how
long has he been in the new position
about a month okay
so why do you not believe he's going to
make more than Bass
um it's just an extremely young company
um so I think the
you know the the future outlook is a
little bit more uncertain than I think
he would have liked so okay so let me
ask this because if he was on the phone
with me I'd go when you sat down and
took this job and they told you at a 90
base what projections did they give you
he should have an idea what his
potential is beyond 90 does he not
even if it's a young company then what's
that what is he expected to make in Year
One
90 90. so 180.
okay so they're projecting that in his
first year he can make a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars
correct okay
uh he was making 150. so I don't
understand where's the pinch
the pinch is because you're you're
extrapolating 90 as your future
and that's that's just not true though
that's if he sells nothing
he sucks if he makes 90.
yeah I guess I
guess I'm taking you're taking an
absolutely mythological stance it's not
just conservative it's just not right
it's wrong
because I mean the chances of him being
there six months from now and making
zero sales
is zero they're gonna fire him if he
makes zero sales yeah or he's going to
quit because they suck so bad he can't
sell their stuff and go get a better
sales job so 90 is not really your
future
zero could be your future but 90 is not
your future no
so I mean this has got to go really
sideways for him to make much less than
he made at the other job so what's
happened is this eight month dry spell
scared the crap out of you girl I don't
blame you by the way I'd be I'd have
been scared too so you're kind of
walking you know you're emotionally
wrung out from this this horrible
process y'all been through for the last
year this has not been a good year right
correct and and if you're not careful
you let that cloud your actual analysis
of the future
based on the wounds of the past that's
what I think I'm hearing
so I think you're okay I don't even know
what your house payment is yet and I
think you're okay
because I'm doing that based on the fact
that you were okay with him making 150
y'all were gonna be okay right before he
got laid off you bought the house where
your ratio's off then
yeah well the ratio yeah it is off it
was off at 150.
based on the 90
um of my income so
okay
he made 150 when you bought the house
were your ratios off then
no we were a little bit over 30 percent
then yeah okay so you if you bought too
much house then then you would sell the
house because you bought too much house
but not because of all the job stuff
he's been through you just made a
mistake before he got laid off being
laid off only accentuated that but now
he has the opportunity to make even more
90 Plus 90 than he did before which
might solve your ratio problems so
um I think you got a pen I think you got
a pinch right now because you've been
through eight months of hell but not
because of where you're going in the
next nine months
so I think the next nine months is going
to tell you if you got to sell the house
or not you don't know today
because you don't you know if he makes
180 would you agree with me you don't
have to sell the house
and so if he's tracking for that six to
nine months from now if he's tracking
towards 180 if the if the trend lines
are going that way then we just keep the
house if the trend lines are are he
looks like he's going to lose his job
because he can't sell it because the
company's young and sucks or he's bad at
it or whatever it is and he's going to
make 90. then we probably do need to
sell this house
okay you following me so let's get out
there a little bit first let's see how
this job works out and that will tell
you if you can afford the house or not
not but but the last eight months
doesn't tell you if you can afford the
house or not only the next date
yeah and and I think for him encourage
him but I hope he's in a mental place to
say I don't like that feeling I've got a
new opportunity it may have been hard
getting here but I'm gonna sell my yeah
absolute fanny off and we're gonna make
up ground you make up ground that we
lost in the last eight months absolutely
and get this done I mean that's it's a
motivator for me if I'm in his shoes it
would be absolutely I don't want to feel
that again but but but Emma you need to
count on zero
or 150 to 180. 90 is really not a
possibility because 90 means failure
which is going to result in zero that's
where we're going to end up there so uh
so you're not being conservative you're
just not being factual when you do that
with yourself you've told yourself I'm
being conservative no you're not you're
just wrong right and that's that's we
see this a lot I've done it we've all
done it we go to the worst case scenario
and then we try to frame everything from
the worst possible case here's what's
interesting she came on and and the way
her mind is working he took a pay cut
right and then we find out he's got a
chance to make more money yeah yeah and
really very likely will yeah hopefully
yeah I mean well no he will because he's
not really the again I don't think he's
going to take a pay cut yeah because if
he takes a pay cut it means he's
probably gone that's true you're right
yep their projection says he's coming
out ahead yeah they did not hire him to
pay him a base and he'll make no sales
that's correct that's a healthy base for
a salesperson that let me tell you that
base gets you fired yeah if you're not
making sales that's true that's true so
it's almost 100 they're gonna move you
won't so in the zero say the chances he
makes Z you know doesn't make something
above 90 and gets to keep the job is
very slim that's correct so I mean I'm
on the other end of this this is we hire
here on these same situations and if
we're going to put you on that base you
know here's your Runway and you better
get the plane off the ground so there's
a wreck on the other end the runway
otherwise right I mean that's it I mean
it's just reality it's not threat it's
just not it's not mean but this is the
reality of the marketplace it's how it's
how things functions man path that does
this to us so hey really good question
I'm sorry for what you all been through
that was painful for you and but don't
let that pain Cloud the way you're doing
your critical thinking on this because I
think you're I think you got a lot
brighter future than you feel like you
do right now that's what it sounds like
to us good question good job to the guys
in the booth Austin Ben James Zach
Andrew good job Ken Coleman that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]